BRANDON LESHCHINSKIY:
Instead of trying
to convince the other person
or persuade the other person,
listen.
Help them empty their heart
and express why they're
frustrated with the situation.
And then they'll be
more likely to listen
to your own experiences
and more receptive to why
you think climate change
matters and is relevant.
SARAH HANSEN: Today
on Chalk Radio,
we're exploring climate action
and how one nonprofit is
providing a framework for young
people to help effect change.
BRANDON LESHCHINSKIY: The thing
about teaching young people,
in particular, is
that young people
are open-minded to new
material, but they're
mature enough to understand
fairly complex concepts.
Ultimately, we hope
that Ambassadors
will teach students,
students will teach families,
and families will demand action.
SARAH HANSEN: I'm your
host, Sarah Hansen.
With us today is
Brandon Leshchinskiy,
a graduate student in a
technology and policy master's
program and the aeronautics
and astronautics master's
program at MIT.
Brandon's also working with
a nonprofit called EarthDNA.
If this organization
sounds familiar to you,
it's because our last guest,
professor of astronautics Dava
Newman, co-founded EarthDNA It's
a global platform for climate
advocacy and action.
Our guest today,
Brandon, helped create
a program called EarthDNA
Ambassadors, which
provides young people with
climate leadership training.
In addition to learning about
the science behind climate
change, Ambassadors also
develop skills focused on
communication, negotiation,
and storytelling.
BRANDON LESHCHINSKIY:
We envision a community
of climate leaders who
engage their own communities
on their campuses at their
schools on climate change.
Current Ambassadors come
from different backgrounds,
whether PhD students in
immunology or undergraduate
students in business.
Some of them have teaching
experience, but not
all of them.
SARAH HANSEN: One of
the tools that EarthDNA
equips their Ambassadors
with is called Climate 101.
Available on MIT OpenCourseWare
and EarthDNA.org,
it's an interactive
workshop that
was designed to
engage communities
around climate change and
motivate people to act.
But changing human
behavior can be
difficult, so Climate
101 starts with something
a bit more approachable--
the power of conversation.
BRANDON LESHCHINSKIY:
Well, I think
talking about it is really
important because I think
that climate change has
the stigma about it where,
if you even bring
it up, you're viewed
as a hippie environmentalist
and alarmist and all
of these things.
And so even by having
conversations about it
and making it normal
to have conversations
about climate
change, you empower
others to do that, as well.
And that's huge because,
for a lot of people,
they just don't hear about
climate change that often,
or if they hear about
it, it's not necessarily
the best information.
And so if we can have people
talking about climate change
in a way that's personal and
meaningful to their family
members, who might
be climate skeptics,
that's one of the best
ways to create the attitude
and behavioral change that's
necessary to actually overcome
the problem of climate change.
SARAH HANSEN: In addition
to normalizing discussions
on climate change, the
Climate 101 presentation
is designed to improve
climate literacy.
That means empowering people to
think critically about climate
change data and research,
and even targeted marketing
campaigns.
BRANDON LESHCHINSKIY:
One of the things
that we actually talk about
in the Climate 101 workshop is
the effect of
different information
campaigns by fossil
fuel companies, who
have a very clear interest in
preventing any kind of climate
action and in promoting
misinformation
among the public,
promoting doubt
among the public about whether
climate change happens.
It's really important
for me that people
are able to sift through
all that competing
information in order to
decide for themselves
whether climate change is real,
whether it matters to them,
and whether they should
do something about it.
Now, I think the answer to
all three of those questions
is yes, but I want
to help people
process this deluge of
information by themselves
and be aware that there are
people that are intentionally
trying to misinform them.
SARAH HANSEN:
Climate literacy is
critical to efforts for
creating a grassroots movement
of climate change action.
Brandon sees the
EarthDNA Ambassadors,
who are between the
ages of 16 and 30,
as the next generation of
climate leaders and educators.
BRANDON LESHCHINSKIY: The thing
about teaching young people,
in particular, is
that young people
are open-minded to new
material, but they're
mature enough to understand
fairly complex concepts.
They're also part of their
parents' trusted networks.
So if we can talk
to young people,
they can talk to their parents.
Ultimately, we hope
that Ambassadors
will teach students,
students will teach families,
and families will demand action.
Ultimately, I think in
creating EarthDNA Ambassadors,
I was really
interested in helping
people who are passionate
about climate change
find their own
voice, and helping
them to express their own
beliefs and their own opinions
and make a change in
their own community.
I think empowering people
who care about climate change
to find their voice and use
it has been one of the most
rewarding things that
I've done, and I'm just
really grateful
for the opportunity
to be part of this community
of people that are all
interested in self-development,
in leadership,
and in climate change.
SARAH HANSEN: In putting
the Climate 101 presentation
together, Brandon
and the EarthDNA team
didn't want to entirely
reinvent the wheel.
They were open to utilizing
many different materials,
from a variety of
reputable sources,
to create a comprehensive
experience for participants.
And part of what
makes it so effective
is that the presentation
has been developed
to appeal to a wide
audience, whether you're
a high school student or a
late career professional.
BRANDON LESHCHINSKIY:
So most climate
change educational materials
focus almost exclusively
on the science, while Climate
101 covers in 45 minutes
the science, the economics, and
the civics of climate change.
And what that allows
us to do is to engage
with people who
wouldn't typically
consider climate change to be
one of their first priorities.
The idea was to create a
single composition that
keeps people's attention,
that keeps people engaged,
that keeps people
interested and excited,
while also sharing a large
amount of information
about climate change from
different perspectives.
And I think that's what
Climate 101 has accomplished.
SARAH HANSEN: And EarthDNA
has data to back that up.
Surveys they've collected show
that, before the presentation,
about half of the
students talked
to their friends or family about
climate change twice a week.
But afterward, the
number of people
participating in
those conversations
jumped to over 80%.
Sometimes, those conversations
can be difficult,
especially when they're
with people who are
skeptical about climate change.
But Climate 101 helps
Ambassadors with that, too.
BRANDON LESHCHINSKIY: When
it comes to climate change,
even the stories
of what's happening
is very different, right?
We have different
interpretations
of different facts that lead
us to different conclusions,
and then we often argue
about those conclusions
without understanding each
other's interpretations
or the observations that
each of us have made.
And so even in bringing up a
climate change conversation,
you have to be aware that you
might be threatening the way
that somebody sees themselves.
Or maybe in engaging
in these conversations,
you are threatening somebody's
sense of patriotism or sense
of being a good person.
Especially in areas
where the economy
is based in fossil fuels,
it can be really difficult
because, ultimately, a
climate change conversation
can amount to an accusation
that that person is not just
providing food for their family,
but also is damaging the Earth
and harming a lot of people.
And so it's really important
to consider all of those things
as you have these climate
change conversations.
So instead of trying to
convince the other person
or persuade the
other person, listen,
help them empty their
heart and express why
they're frustrated
with the situation.
And then they'll be
more likely to listen
to your own experiences
and more receptive to why
you think climate change
matters and is relevant.
SARAH HANSEN:
Something else that
helps the Climate
101 presentation
resonate across
different audiences
is the incorporation
of local insights.
This targeted approach
helps distill the larger,
sometimes overwhelming
issue of climate change
into something more digestible.
BRANDON LESHCHINSKIY: One of
the problems with climate change
discussions is that
it's a huge problem,
right, it affects
the entire world,
and that happens over
the course of decades.
But people live their lives
at home or in their town,
and people live their
lives day to day.
So when you start talking about
these massive, overwhelming
changes, it can be really
easy to just dismiss them
as either things
that don't affect me
or things that I can't
do anything about.
The idea of creating localized
insights and personally
meaningful insights
is that we need
to talk about climate
change in a way that's
relevant to the
intended audience.
And so if we can say, for
example, well, here in Boston,
the city was actually
considering building seawalls
because of anticipated
flooding, now, all of a sudden,
that's something that's
happening in my neighborhood.
That's something that's like,
oh my god, that's coming for me.
That's not the Earth is warming
by 2 degrees Celsius, which
doesn't really mean
much to me, it's,
oh my god, there's going
to be flooding in Boston?
SARAH HANSEN: The more
I talked with Brandon,
the more I wanted to
know what was personally
motivating him to engage
in climate action work.
He began to talk about the
intergenerational experiences
of his own family.
BRANDON LESHCHINSKIY: A
few years ago, my family
celebrated its 25th anniversary
in the United States.
We were all at my
grandparents' place, seated
around this beautiful
dining room table in front
of a gorgeous display
case full of fancy china,
and my grandma was
bustling around,
making sure we all had enough
of that fatty and meaty
Ukrainian food that
my family loves.
And my family was
telling stories,
stories of my childhood that
I'd been hearing for years,
but stories that helped us
reflect on what it meant
to come to the United States.
My grandpa told
how he'd only taken
one flight in his
whole life, and it
was to come to
the United States,
because the only thing that
he feared more than flying
was staying in a
collapsed Soviet state.
My grandma, how she came to the
US without knowing any English,
and not only learned English,
but also learned how to code,
and recently retired as a
senior software developer.
My mom, how she, after
four months here,
was caught stealing a
$7 bottle of face cream
because she wanted to get a
gift for her mom's birthday
and she couldn't afford it.
And my mom went on and started
a business that ended up
putting me through college,
but even 25 years later, she
was still so embarrassed
and ashamed of that moment.
I turned to my dad, and I
asked him whether he ever
missed the Ukraine.
It's where he grew up.
It's where his friends are.
And he turned to me and
responded in Russian
that only in his
worst nightmare would
he ever wake up
back in that hell.
And to me, that moment
really crystallizes this idea
that so much of
who we are and what
we have is determined
by choices that people
make before we're even born.
And that's just such
a great injustice.
And climate change
exemplifies that.
I think climate change is
one of the great injustices
of our time.
It was created primarily by
wealthy, privileged people
in developed nations,
and it will primarily
affect the vulnerable, the
poor, the sick, in many cases
people who never even
contributed to the problem.
I think that, for those of
us who have an opportunity
to fight that injustice, for
those of us who have benefited
from being fortunate
and from being born
in the right place
at the right time,
we have a real obligation
to help the people who
don't necessarily have
those opportunities now
reach those same opportunities.
And in this case, it
means doing something
about this massive global
problem that will eventually
affect all of us, but
is already affecting
many of the most vulnerable.
SARAH HANSEN: One
important component
in tackling climate
change is recognizing
that it's a collective
issue that affects just
about everyone.
Brandon incorporated interactive
activities into the Climate 101
curriculum to help simulate
how these collective dilemmas
can play out.
These activities are
modeled on the concept
of the tragedy of the
commons, where people tend
to act selfishly
when they believe
that their individual
actions won't make an impact.
A classic example of the
tragedy of the commons
is the gradual overfishing
of a public waterway.
And in some ways,
this concept mirrors
what we've seen throughout
the COVID-19 pandemic.
While these issues
are quite different,
of course, they do both require
collaborative efforts to make
a real difference
in tackling them,
and our everyday
choices actually
can have an immediate impact.
BRANDON LESHCHINSKIY: I think
COVID is a really great example
of collective dilemmas.
And in the US, in
particular, we have
this very individualist
attitude, personal liberty
above all else.
And personal liberty is
obviously super important,
but we see in a case like
COVID that, when crises arise,
sometimes we do need to act
for the collective good.
And that can be
really difficult,
but climate change is similar.
The longer we waited to
take action on COVID,
the more drastic the
action had to be.
And with climate
change, it's similar.
Had we started really focusing
on reducing our emissions
and transitioning
to renewable energy,
as well as making some of the
other changes we need to make,
in 2000, we could have
done it pretty gradually,
and at a reasonable pace.
But we waited 20 years, and it
looks like we're still waiting.
So now, the action
that we have to take
is much more drastic than
had we done it 20 years ago.
And if we continue
to wait, that action
will have to be
still more drastic.
So yesterday is better
than today, and today
is better than tomorrow, to
quote one of the articles
that I read regarding
COVID, but that also applies
equally well to climate change.
SARAH HANSEN: Many people
worry that attention
on climate change has weakened
due to the COVID-19 pandemic,
but Brandon sees a
space for optimism,
and views these overlapping
crises as an opportunity.
BRANDON LESHCHINSKIY: I think,
for a lot of climate activists,
right now is difficult in
terms of climate activism
because COVID is a really
serious and really urgent
problem, and it can
be hard to spare
any attention or any
emotion for climate
change, this other scary thing.
But times of crisis are
actually times of opportunity.
And so right now is
a time that people
feel like they need connection
and purpose and community.
And so right now is
an opportunity for us
to continue growing and
giving people those things,
and it's also an opportunity
to fight even harder for some
of the changes that we
need to make in order
to overcome the climate
change issue, as well
as the COVID issue.
SARAH HANSEN: Much of Brandon's
work around this project, which
inspires others to
take a leadership
role in their own way, has been
driven by his own experiences
with leaders in his life.
Throughout the
COVID-19 pandemic,
he's found strong leaders in his
advisor, Professor Dava Newman
at MIT, who you heard from
in our last episode, and Rand
Wentworth, Brandon's
environmental leadership
professor at the
Harvard Kennedy School.
BRANDON LESHCHINSKIY:
They have both
been such incredible
models of what it means
to be a leader during a crisis.
They have been hyperattentive
to their students' needs,
so empathetic, such
good listeners,
adaptive and flexible
and positive.
And that has been
really inspiring for me.
Empathy is everything, and
it's just so hard right now.
You know, my emotional
reserves that I usually
use to accomplish tasks
that I don't necessarily
find as interesting are gone.
At this point, I'm
just hyperfocused
on staying sane, staying
happy, staying healthy.
And Rand and Dava both
really understand that.
And they start every
meeting with a check-in.
How are you guys?
What can I do to help?
And that's something that
I hope to take forward
as an immediate response in
a crisis, is to figure out,
OK, how are the people that are
affected by this crisis doing,
and what can I do
to accommodate them
and to make it easier for them.
SARAH HANSEN:
Brandon understands
that many people, when faced
with the COVID-19 pandemic as
well as the threat
of climate change,
are experiencing a
kind of doom fatigue.
If you seek it out, there
can be an overwhelming amount
of bad news about both crises.
But Brandon is working on
reframing this thinking
into something more
approachable so that people
can carry forward
with important work
in their own manageable way,
without feeling like it's all
just too much to handle.
BRANDON LESHCHINSKIY:
There are definitely
times when I also feel like,
why am I even bothering?
There's so much out
there to improve.
What can I do?
There's a story that I love.
It's told by Wangari
Maathai, who's
a Nobel Peace Prize winner
for her environmental work.
She tells a story of a
great big forest fire,
and how all of the animals
are running out of the forest,
and they're standing
next to it as it burns.
But one animal, the hummingbird,
starts going to a nearby lake
and carrying one drop
of water at a time
to douse the forest fire.
And all the other animals are
asking, what are you doing?
You're so small.
This fire is so big.
You can't possibly
do anything about it.
The elephant is standing
there with its big trunk,
all the other animals that
are also much bigger, just
doing nothing.
The hummingbird keeps on going.
And then finally,
without missing a beat,
the hummingbird says,
I'm doing the best I can.
And Wangari Maathai
says, we should all
be like hummingbirds.
We should all just do
the best that we can.
And some days, that's
not very much at all.
And that's OK.
But we should all remember
that we each can do something,
and that that matters, and that
that's enough in that moment.
SARAH HANSEN: In our individual
work on climate change,
it's OK to take the
approach of the hummingbird
to make a difference.
If you're interested in becoming
an EarthDNA Ambassador or want
to learn more about their
training program and materials,
head to
EarthDNA.org/ambassadors.
You can also find the Climate
101 presentation slides,
a video of Brandon giving
the presentation, Ambassador
program application, handouts
and volunteer resources
on our MIT
OpenCourseWare website.
And by the way, did you know
OpenCourseWare is turning 20?
It's taken a community to
bring OCW to this moment,
and we want you to be a part
of it and what comes next.
Please join us for a
virtual celebration
of OCW's impact,
community, and the future
of open sharing on
Wednesday, April 7th,
2021 at 12:00 PM Eastern time.
You can register using the
link at our show notes,
or just tune in live to OCW's
YouTube, Instagram, or Facebook
pages.
Thank you for making these
first two decades possible,
and thanks so much for listening
to the Chalk Radio podcast.
Until I see you on
April 7th, signing off
from Cambridge,
Massachusetts, I'm
Sarah Hansen from
MIT OpenCourseWare.
AUDIO BUMPER: Ma, park the car.